[Music]
I'm tired of politics
let's get that Punk blood so this is
amazing of course we have no idea where
he is but I love where your head's at
yep no family maybe there was a
girlfriend or someone he worked with at
the coffee shop at the coffee shop why
would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a
minimum-wage job because he needed
access to that building because that's
where the money's hidden all right we
gotta get there quick maybe we should
take the chopper death blade Sidewinder
it's go time Roger that wet blanket snow
from now on call me hello Raymond
[Music]
captain wuntch good to see you but if
you're here who's guarding Hades huh
meat from the street
sounds like a fun treat I'm a poet and
didn't even know I was rhyming those
words but it happened anyway it's a
great idea partner Ruth I'm gonna be
straight with you I accidentally knocked
up a woman robbed you know me I see a
pair of thick weighty breasts and all
logic flies out the window I don't know
what's going on down at police
headquarters and no one will tell me
anything so you're saying that not
knowing what your bosses are up to it's
driving you a little crazy you've used
my logic against me
well played Timmy well played
thank you sir look at that you helped me
find my smile
hello detective is there a reason you're
interrupting me mid suit whoa you really
made the balloon arch made no I birthed
her do you want to know how I actually
hurt my wrist
yes I was looking Kevin and I attend a
class for fitness and for fun oh my god
I've mastered all the moves the pizza
toss the tornado the Scorpion the oopsie
doodle
why are you telling me this because no
one will ever believe you No son of a
[ __ ] so who was your partner back when
you caught the Brooklyn broiler martin
ormankupp he was a great partner smart
loyal homophobic but not racist in those
days that was pretty good I've never
been more proud of you for anything in
your life
I mean I've solved a lot of cases for
you and yet crime is continued the math
thing isn't the problem night shifts
keeping you and Kevin apart
you two just need a bone just hate again
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer Oh what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business
don't ever speak to me like that again
that dude is pent up now he knows
problem solved vindication kantaria is
intelligent and inquisitive with a bold
personality a bold personality we know
whether it's code for to the Fitch
sergeant I'd like you to meet Richard
and Dan they are puppies very cute sir
maybe you twins would like some little
furry friends I'm sorry sir but that's
impossible with the twins learning how
to walk chaos reigns at the Jeffords
household I can't let those innocent
pups into that madhouse Terry won't do
you like that I understand
just know you have disappointed all
three of us
that's cold sir if you excuse me
sergeant Wells we need to go to the BRB
it's BRB time where the RBA
makes bass you make space this closet is
for people who are freaking out oh I'm
fully freaking out I just experimented
with an unfamiliar acronym in public BRB
what does even mean be right back it was
the same number of syllables of the
acronym was the point this is great I
had no idea captain Holt was interesting
food I have zero interest in food if it
were feasible my diet would consist
entirely of a flavorless beige smoothies
containing all the nutrients required by
the human animal there were very few
black detectives did I ever tell you
what my first day on the job was like
hello I'm Raymond holt are you here to
turn yourself in it's 9:00 a.m. why is
no one working Amy Santiago is a few
minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why I like to play I'd say she's
in line at the bank this is fun it is
fun but you're all wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grate and is having terrible sex with a
mole man there she is
Amy where have you been we've been
worried sick do you care to explain
yourself I'm just 70 seconds late it's
not a big deal don't worry about it
Santiago you will tell us and you will
tell us now there's a problem at the
bank
hot damn I've been researching ways to
raise morale and I found an interesting
article in a scientific journal Oh was
it from the American Journal of no one
cares according to a recent study the
physical act of smiling can improve your
mood I suggest we give it a shot
hmm now your try
big smiles bigger bigger great now we
just have to stay like this for the next
few hours can you feel it working I
don't have any enamel on my teeth so the
cold air is excruciating maybe you
brushed your teeth once in a while this
wouldn't be a problem
I do brush my teeth they're decaying
from acid reflux
you're dirty yourself for like a you're
not Australian Gena gets stuffed you
drongo okay so seriously too much
exposure to air they will turn to dust
this isn't working out as well as I'd
hoped
time for the next level forced laughing
[Laughter]
jackpot let's do this and how am I
supposed to get all the way up there and
now it's time to send in our cute little
secret weapon
I'm ready captain I love the nickname no
Charles not you I was talking about
cheddar oh right
obviously over the past month I've had
them trained to retrieve planks and now
boy it's time to make daddy proud yes
sir I could not have been more clearly
talking to the dog Oh sir I thought you
said this was my case I gave you two
weeks I'm done fending off the organized
crime unit squad since Peralta's
briefing was cut short you can all use
this time to clean up your desks look at
this place half-eaten food crumpled
tissues pictures of your families what's
wrong with pictures if you love someone
you'll remember what they look like
you're a captain tough weekend I went to
Barbados with my husband we won't hats
out of palm fronds and swam with the
stingrays I've never been happier
guys impossible to read don't even try
that is without question the funniest
story I've ever heard what'd you do
what'd you say nothing we just said
welcome back and laughed with him about
all the weight he gained in France why
is everyone just standing around get
back to work
so long tank tech I gained three pounds
in Paris three pounds Sarge
that painting is tight it's terrible the
brushwork is sloppy is poor use of
negative space I'm a fraud not at all
I'd like to take this home for my
husband he'll be glad you made me look
so happy
rise and shine detectives rise and shine
Peralta I want you to bring everyone up
to speed you slept in your office and
you look exactly the same
how were you talking about my hair's a
mess hey captain mind if we sit
everything okay nothing's okay lunch
circling me like a shark frenzied by
Chum the task force turning into a
career-threatening quagmire an internal
affairs investigation casting doubt upon
my integrity and you ask is everything
okay
I am buffeted by the winds of my foes
enmity and cast about by the towering
waves of cruel fate yet I a captain I'm
no longer able to command my vessel my
precinct from my customary helm my
office and you ask is everything okay
I've worked the better part of my years
on earth overcoming every prejudice and
fighting for the position I hold and now
I feel it being ripped from my grasp and
with it
the very essence of what defines me as a
man and you ask is everything okay
you